the Ukrainian government said back in
October that more than two and a half
thousand educational institutions had
been damaged in the fighting that 331
schools had been fully destroyed now
research by the center for information
resilience shared exclusively with Sky
News has verified 381 incidents in which
Ukrainian schools universities
orphanages and nurseries were damaged
during the first year of the war now
this shows when and where those
instances have been occurring most of
the damage is in the east of the country
in our analysis shows that one in every
seven schools in eastern Ukraine has
been damaged or destroyed and the pace
is simply unrelenting since March last
year there have been at least a dozen
incidents every single month and you can
see it's even picked up over the last
few months as Russia launched its winter
offensive the schools have been hit
since the very start Mario poll in the
South has been under Russian occupation
for more than a year now and this shows
the damage sustained during the fighting
for the city at the start of the
conflict I want to take you through one
of those instant is to show how research
has verified the damage this was posted
on social media showing the aftermath of
a strike on a building cleaved in half
that's in yellow there now a different
angle we can find the same building try
and locate where this is by looking for
similar features and so there we can see
where we've got it boxed up for you
there same box in yellow and that in
Orange now putting those all together
lets us merge this with a satellite
imagery and confirm this is number 20
School in mariupo but it can also happen
far from the front lines in the capital
key this is a crater next to Happy Time
kindergarten highlighted in Orange we
can locate the school here too the roof
is the same we can see the same building
put it on a map and that helps us put it
in context the kindergarten is next to
this industrial complex which is owned
by a company that makes Munitions that
was probably the intended target but as
the fighting shifts so does the damage
backward has seen a fierce battle over
recent months and so it's got some of
the most recent damage as that fighting
has occurred now some of that is likely
the result of indiscriminate shelling
but the researchers believe some
bombings have been more targeted for
instance in the city of kharkiv
once the front line has shift away from
harkive City Schools were still being
hardly hit
um an analysis on the areas surrounding
the school's damage so that it was like
suggested that there was more a
systematic Target targeting rather than
a white product of indiscriminate
shelling
and really nowhere is safe this chart
Compares each incident against the
school with the wars shifting front
lines anything gray is inside Russian
held territory and you can see most of
these are close to the front lines
within 100 kilometers of them but also
all along this chart you have these
points up here that is a long way well
behind the front lines and because of
the war the charity World Vision
International says that 3.6 million
Ukrainian children are likely to miss
out on education